if you were to steal a man that case
against God or the existence of God you
find the most convincing argument is
there's evil in the world therefore
there's no God there's too much of it
yeah if I were to steal man that
argument I do what Stephen Fry does I
would do what dostoyevsky's Yvonne does
I I would do exactly that I would say
there's just too much and then if you
want to keep pressing it um animal
suffering so we talk about human
suffering but the suffering of animals
over the eons and so on
um isn't there just too much suffering
to be reconciled with a with an
infinitely good God and that's again
Thomas Aquinas I've just used his very
steel manned argument you mentioned that
uh again on Reddit somebody asked who
your favorite
um Communicator of atheist ideas was and
you mentioned uh Christopher Hitchens
yeah are there other ideas
um
for atheism do you find particularly
challenging well that's the one it's the
problem of evil the other objection in
Aquinas which has a lot of contemporary
resonance is
can't we just explain everything through
natural causes why would you have to
invoke a cause beyond the causes in the
world so as I'm trying to explain let's
say for Aquinas motion causality you
know finality
can I just do that with natural causes
wouldn't that suffice to explain it so I
get like when naturalists are speaking
or people that are pure materialists
they'll just say no that's perfectly
adequate a scientific account of reality
is utterly adequate to our experience
um so I would steel man that and say
well show me why we need something more
and to do that you got to get out of
Plato's Cave it seems to me because that
my objection to naturalism
is it it it's staying within the realm
of the immediately empirically
observable and making the mistake of
saying that's all there is to being
that's all there is that needs to be
explained and long before we get to
religion just stay with Plato the first
step out of the cave if you combine it
out with the parable of the line is
mathematical objects and and I'm with
those the many people that would say
mathematics is an experience of the
immaterial
I've stepped out of a merely empirical
physical naturalistic world the minute I
understand
a pure number or a pure equation or a
pure mathematical relationship uh which
would obtain in any possible World which
are not tied to to space and time uh
that's the first step out of the cave
and then that leads to the more
metaphysical reflections
for example in the nature of being I
mean so I could I could talk about this
thing as a physical object and I can
analyze it at all kinds of levels and
follow all the scientists you know up
and down through this thing and fine
fine but I'm still in Plato's Cave I'm
still looking at the flickering images
on the wall but when I step out of that
into the mathematical realm I I have
entered a different realm of being seems
to me do you think it's possible for the
cave to expand so large that it
accomplishes the whole world meaning
is it possible to is it possible that
we're just clueless right now in terms
of
uh scientifically speaking with most of
the world we haven't figured out yet but
do you think it's possible through
science to know God to look outside the
world so it's fundamentally the limit of
the empirical scientific method is that
we can't know some of these very big
questions no I I you know I love this
I'm not a scientist and I was never all
that good at science you know I was more
of humanities guy but I love and respect
the scientists but I hate scientism and
scientism is rampant today with
especially young people the reduction of
all knowledge to the scientific form of
knowledge and I I'm a vehement opponent
of that there are dimensions of being
that are not capturable through a
scientific method of mere observation
hypothesis formation experimentation Etc
as great as that is as wonderful as that
is but it's still I think within Plato's
Cave and that's not to say it's not real
it's just at a relatively low level of
reality
um you step out of Plato's Cave when you
go into the pure mathematics that's
right you know that article I just came
across it recently and discovered this
whole literature around it is Eugene
vigner's article 1960 called the
unreasonable applicability of
mathematics to the physical sciences I
think that's the title of it or
Effectiveness or something like that
yeah but what's so cool is you know he's
not a religious man he was a kind of a
secular Jew
um but yet he uses the word miracle like
eight times in that article and because
he just is so impressed by the fact that
high complex mathematics describes so
accurately the physical world and can be
used to to create things and to
manipulate and why should that be true
that there's something very weirdly
mysterious about that relationship you
know and I would say it's because you
you stepped into a higher order of being
which is inclusive of a lower level
being that's the platonic approach is
that as you move now I'm going to
different metaphor you move to higher
levels they're inclusive of the lower
levels yeah there's some magic there
that seems to at least in our current
understanding of science uh to be not
quite capturable even Consciousness the
idea of Consciousness can I ask you
where do you think the laws of nature
come from so I mean sort of the vigner
question where does the Deep
the Deep
mathematical structure of things come
from how do you explain that the
mathematical structure
or the fact that the structures is
somehow pleasing and beautiful because
those are different those are two
different but we do the first one for
I'm just curious where do you think it
comes from
I tend to believe even in terms of
physics we don't really know what's
going on there's so so so much more to
be discovered where um walking around in
the dark trying to figure out little
puzzles here and there and we're patting
ourselves in the back and how many
puzzles we've discovered so far even
ghetto's in completeness theorem what
are the limits of mathematics axiomatic
systems I don't
I don't know what is the purpose of
mathematics what is the power of
mathematics is it just a useful tool to
um
study
the world around us or is it something
deeper that we're just discovering and
I'm all I know for my emotional
perspective now I am an engineer I'm a
robotics AI person from an emotional
perspective I just find the whole thing
beautiful yeah but that's really cool to
me that's very interesting clue
see one of the arguments for God is
based on the intelligibility of the
world this very it's like vignor it's
very peculiar fact it seems to me that
the world is so radically intelligible
why should that be true why should it be
the case that being has this
intelligible structure to it so it
corresponds to an inquiring mind so
Aquinas can say that the the
intelligible in Act is the intellect and
act meaning there's some there's some
deep correspondence between this and
that and it it's I'm with vigner that's
I think really weird and unreasonable
and strange
now my answer is because the the creator
of the universe is a great mind and uh
has stamped the world with
intelligibility
in the beginning was the word right and
the Word was with God and all things
came to be through the word don't we
shouldn't picture that so much it's a
it's gesturing In This Very powerful
Direction
there's an intelligence that has imbued
the world with intelligibility
and and we discover that you know
there's something about the Simplicity
of the way the world works that's that's
where the beauty comes from and yes
there's something profound to the
mechanism whatever that is
um God that brought that to be the
thought of into being that the world has
been said that when the Bible says that
God God said let there be light and
there was light God said well again we
don't literalize The Poetry but it's
it's very rich that God spoke the world
into being
so that means it's it's been it's been
imbued with intelligibility from the
beginning
um they say that you know the condition
for the possibility of the of the
western physical sciences was a
basically Christian idea namely that the
world is not God
therefore I can I can analyze it
experiment upon it I can I don't
divanize it I don't have a mystical
relationship to the world it's not God
but secondly that it's it's absolutely
in every nook and cranny intelligible
and those two ideas are correlated to
the idea of creation so it's been
created it's not God's other than God
but yet it's touched in every Dimension
by God's mind and when those two things
are in place The Sciences get underway
you know I don't worship the world
anymore but I'm also utterly confident
when I can come to know it and those are
theological ideas well we live in this
world
so we can solve quite a lot of problems
of This World by making an assumption
that this world is fully understandable
and we don't need to worry about what's
outside the world in some sense in order
to build Bridges and Rockets and
computers and all that kind of stuff
it's only when we get to the questions
that are deeper about why we're here at
all what does it mean to be good all
those kinds of things do we need to
reach outside of this world what can I
interest another one so I talked about
mathematics I think it's stepping out of
a cave it's stepping out of just the
purely empirical you know world
but the refactor we use a word like
Universe to me is very interesting even
if you say multiple universes to me that
it's like well they're they're so
whatever this the whole is the totality
universum turn toward the one
um
why would we call it that why would why
would we just call it an aggregate it's
just an aggregate of stuff it's an
aggregate walk but we call it a universe
and my answer from the classical
metaphysical tradition is is the
intuition of being so I immediately
experience things here the color and
shape and I can measure them but when
I've really stepped out of the cave and
I've now engaged Beyond mathematics even
I'm now into metaphysical reflection I'm
interested not just in this thing as an
object and how it's colored and shaped
and what it's atoms and quarks and all
that are that's fine but I'm interested
now in
wasn't mean to say this thing is real so
what makes this a being
and then what are the characteristics of
being so not from Aristotle the
Heidegger you know this question of of
the nature of being but see I would say
we call it a universe because it's
turned toward the one of being it's this
intuition that whatever from quarks to
galaxies to whatever give me a billion
other universes that it would still be
existence right it's turned toward the
one that being unites our experience and
so now I'm at the metaphysical level of
analysis I've taken another step out of
the cave in Plato's language I'm at the
formal level now Beyond mathematics
level forms and and the formal is
inclusive of the mathematical which is
inclusive of the physical
and I think that's Eugene vigner is that
the mathematical includes the physical
it it is metaphysically prior to it
but here we are sitting in the physical
trying to make sense of why the
unreasonable effectiveness of the thing
that's uh it's beyond which is the
mathematics my answer is God and I I
don't know what better answer and I as I
read Victor he wasn't ready to say that
but I think the language is gesturing
who I was reading someone recently some
very well-known physicist who said his
answer to vigner's question is
that whoever is responsible for the
universe must be a mathematician
and I thought yeah that's right